with washing our hands right before the
face.
And the answer is that is not a an
obligation
of that is one of the things that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam would
sometimes do and sometimes not do.
was set up. Sometimes he would wash his
hands first, other times he would not.
And the obligations of
are the steps mentioned in the sixth
verse of the fifth chapter of the Quran
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
These are the four steps and really five
because
they are mentioned in order.
These are the five obligations of Udu
and succession that they be done that
these all be done together. This is
understood from the seak of the verse.
This is understood from the way that the
verse is structured. So all of them are
found there. Washing the hands before
beginning woo
is something that the prophet would do
sall.ai Wasam
because of the general reason that
whenever he would make wudoo, it's
usually
because he had relieved himself, right?
He would relieve himself and then he
would make wudoo and he would always
make wudoo right after relieving
himself. Rarely would he not make wudoo.
And so usually when he is finished
relieving himself he would begin to make
his wudoo and he would start with what?
Washing his hands. The same thing goes
when a person wakes up from sleep. It is
an obligation that the first thing a
person does when he wakes up from sleep
is to wash his hands or to wash our
hands. The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says
He says because while you were asleep,
you don't know where your hands have
been. You don't know where your hands
have been. So the sunnah is to always
wash your hands and sense the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam would usually be
making wudoo after relieving himself or
after waking up. He would wash his hands
before he would start with the wudoo.
But the first obligation of wubul is
washing the face. And we said part of
the face is what? The mouth and the
nose. How would he do this? He would
take the water in his right hand, cup it
this. He would take them together,
half into his mouth and half into his
nose. And then he would blow it out with
his left hand.
And al meaning he would move the water
around in his mouth and then spit it
out. He would do this three times or two
times or at least one time. All are
correct.
The obligatory is once.
The sunnah is two or three times. But
the bare minimum one time.
And
what about what we see people do
sometimes?
You know, what people do
is often times what gets worked into
other people's
other people's actions.
And it's
it's a it's a double-edged sword, right?
What is something that if I want you to
buy a product,
one of the things
really one of the six universal things
that if I show you, you'll be more
likely to buy my product.
Well, I show you other people doing it.
If I show you other people buying my
product,
it shortcircuits something. It's a
shortcut to decision making that human
beings have. Why? Because we assume
being that human beings are intelligent
creatures
that they are not going to do something
without thinking it through, without
having evidence. But what we fail to
realize is that me seeing someone do
something and doing it just because he
did it and assuming the burden of proof
was on him,
he could have been doing exactly what
I'm doing and that is copying the other
guy, the next guy, assuming that the
next guy had the evidence, right? But
that doesn't occur to us.
So human beings naturally
when they see people want something or
do something immediately it starts
becoming interesting.
All right. Anyone here who's ever had a
fruit tree in your in your front yard
you'll know what I'm talking about. What
do I mean by that?
If you see a tree in front of someone's
house, a fruit tree, and the fruit is
growing and just dropping on the ground,
the birds are eating it or
and the next day you walk by, you see
this tree, always see the the the the
fruits all over the ground. You say,
"You know what? I'm going to bring a bag
by with me next time and I'm going to
pick this fruit up and I'm going to
start eating it myself. What's going to
happen immediately as soon as you start
doing that? 99 times out of 100,
huh?
[Arabic recitation]
nobody's eating it. Of course you're
going to take it off the tree. What's
going to happen? Huh? All of a sudden,
the owner of the tree is very interested
in this tree. This is his tree. And this
is his fruit. And why are you picking
what? Well, the fruit's always on the
ground. No, I want this fruit. Now, why
does he want the fruit? Cuz he saw
someone else interested in it. It's
human nature, more or less.
Never assume when it comes to acts of
worship
that someone has vetted
an act of worship before doing it. Never
assume that. Especially in days of
ignorance and in lands far from the
lands of knowledge. Unless it's a
scholar, a student of knowledge, someone
who's known for his knowledge, known for
his research, okay, that's a different
story.
However, just assuming that someone
knows or has vetted something before
they went and did it, don't ever assume
it when it comes to the religion of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, no matter how
logical it seems.
So, you'll you'll see in wudoo lots of
this because people make wudoo together.
So, one of the things you'll see is
people sticking their fingers in their
nose to clean their nose out during
wudoo.
Not
because they need to clean their nose,
but because it's part of their wudoo.
Never did the prophet sallall.aii
do this ever. This is not part of
woodoo.
Likewise using the finger
to brush the teeth in wudoo.
Never was it narrated authentically that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam did
this. There is a narration very obscure
narration of Ana Medic that he used to
do this. But even that narration is
subject that narration is is not
necessarily authentic.
Likewise,
separation of the mouth and nose. Never
was the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam narrated to have separated
between the mouth and the nose ever.
Ever
when he would take the water, he would
take some in the mouth and some in the
nose with one take.
However, sometimes you'll see people
make wool. They will do the mouth three
times and then the nose three times and
then the face. We've seen this, right?
This is not the sunnah, but it it is
valid. For what that's worth, it's
valid. It's permissible, but it's not
the sunnah. It's not something that he
or his companions ever did. They would
always take the mouth and nose together,
right?
And likewise, when it comes to washing
the face,
one of the things he did is that because
his beard was very thick, what's
obligatory
is to wash the face. And the parameters
of the face are the hairline,
the the common hairline, right? Someone
who's balding, their hairline is back
here. No, the common hairline
which is just above the forehead
to the edges of the ears
and the bottom of the face. This is the
parameters of the face in the Arabic
language and they are no different in
the Quran and Sunnah. And so washing the
face, all that is obligatory is to wash
the face. The beard does not have to be
washed.
However,
what he did
was something not he wouldn't do it
every time. He would do it sometimes and
it's referred to as
what is
if you read
in a book
it will give you
the idea or the image
that he was you know working the water
into his beard. But that's not what is
meant by
with respect to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's woo. This is how he would do.
So he would wash his hands. And by the
way, another common misconception
is only using the right hand to wash the
face. Never did he make wudoo this.
Wasallam. He would always use both hands
this. He would cup the water and
wash the face. Now after the third time,
if he wished to do this,
he would wet his hand,
right?
And he would insert
his fingers, his wet fingers into his
beard just this. No more. That's
it. just you saw me do right now.
It wasn't anything more intense than
that. And that is only for who? People
who have a beard thick enough that you
cannot see the skin underneath.
Right? So he would wash and then he
would wet his hand
and he would put it under his beard like
this. These three fingers would come out
this.
That's it. He would not work the water
into his beard here. He would not work
the water into his beard here. He would
not cup the water and put it under. None
of those things were part of his woo.
And that
that is something which is
at its greatest it is what? Preferable
because it's not something he did all
the time. To the point that
vehemently rejected
until finally someone came and was able
to
narrate to him a strong chain of
narration to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam that he used to do it. So in
the earlier days of Malik and even what
was assumed of his med later by most
of his students is not to do
which articulates what I mean Malik was
in Medina and he was with the generation
that was with the generation that was
with the companions.
And so Islam was still fresh and and and
yet in spite of that he had not seen
until this one instance. So this tells
us that what is what is rare and is
and so
would be in this way only. However, what
is obligatory person? Even if he has a
beard to hear,
right? Even if you've seen some people
their beard is so thick, right, that you
can't even
it it looks one
piece, right?
Even if a person's beard were that thick
or especially if a person's beard is
thick, the sunnah is to wash the
parameters of the face. That is it.
Nothing more than that.
ambu
just a reminder as well that tonight we
have thear
for you know those who are fasting
and if you're not fasting we're not
going to demand evidence of your
valid fast before allowing you in. So
we'll let it slide in.